yeah it would be interesting to know
who's joining from hamburg and
who's joining from other places
i think i can already ask that on the
chat
can we call it pause
okay
oh we have in mexico here that's very
nice luna work with everyone there but
okay guys anyone from hamburg a hello
from hamburg we see one okay
oh that's very nice we have we have
latin america here
that's very nice thank you so much you
guys that's very great
the rest of the word is fantastic yeah
let's get some data
could this be more hamburg there's like
more
rest of the world
hamburg is winning
we have someone that it will it's in
geneva but it was here in hamburg before
so okay
netherlands pretty good
someone said my moy i learned it that my
mind is not happening here in hamburg
because it's already too much people are
just saying that somewhere else you know
so it's like it's
only with one more so i don't know if
the one one is hamburg or not
okay we have 42 people on the call
should we
start or start very good
so first thank you everyone to be here
with us we are very happy to have
this joint meetup today pi data and one
word
my name is camila uh and i'm going to
start this
event with you before we get started
then just that you are aware about it we
are going to record this session
uh to publish on the youth pi data
youtube channel
so in case you don't want to be in the
video
or if you don't want your voice to be uh
on the internet your name and so on
please feel free to just rename yourself
on on zone
and also to keep that in mind if you
have any questions you're always free
like to raise your hand we're also going
to explain a little bit about that
or just put your question on on the chat
so just have that in mind we are
recording this
session and if you have questions as i
mentioned
you can just go here on zone and you can
raise your hands and then we are going
to unmute you
that you can make your questions in case
you feel very shy and you don't want to
talk at all
no worries you just can write your
questions on the chat and we are going
to ask it for you
if you want we already started it for
those that are arriving now
please feel free to just uh type in on
the chat
where are you calling from we would be
very happy to know
uh more about you as well also you can
share about your experience with data
science while you're here on this meetup
and so on and so on
so your hosts for tonight christian
everyone
would you like to introduce yourself oh
mora hi i'm christian i'm
hosting this together with camilla and
anya today and i'm a data scientist when
i'm not volunteering for
pi data of course that's connected um
glad to have you all here hi my name is
camila i work as an i.t consultant as
buyer's dog in my my normal life
very happy to be here and hosting this
together with christian and anya
now it's my turn
hi everybody especially those who signed
up through the women techmakers meetup
because today we are doing a joint
meetup with the pi data
meetup and yes i'm anja i'm
leading the nonprofit organization one
world which is
organizing the women techmakers meetups
and hamburg
very nice so this is our host for
tonight
and this is a little bit about pi data
so
we are a global community for developers
and users of open source data tools
it's a non-profit originally located in
the us
so non-focus and here are our channels
so if you want to follow us on twitter
so we have here pi data homework that
are the other channels from
uh pi data global uh and also the
records of this
meetup it's going to be on the youtube
channel of pi data
and i would like to hand over now to
anya that she can present about
my word yes so
i wanted to use the
wait let me
[Music]
share my screen
this word
uh i hope it's working now
it works
can you see the mind work presentation
now yes
okay
takes a couple of minutes okay
okay um so thank you for giving me the
opportunity to also present more in the
world
for those who signed absolutely women
take makers meet up probably you
you've already heard of modern world but
for those who are
joining with high data meet up um i
would
like to introduce more in for a few
minutes so
um my world is a non-profit organization
it's a
minor cigar ein and our official goal
is education in computer science
and our inofficial goal
is doing something for equality
in the field of computer science
i was actually we have a speaker from
israel here tonight
i was actually inspired by c codes
and their goal is uh to have 50 female
software developers and i can
only uh uh confirmed this goal
um this is also what we would like to
achieve with moin world
um more in world originated through the
women techmakers meetup which we are
still organizing
and one year later
moin world was officially born
financially it's supported by all these
nice companies that you can see here on
the slide
big tech companies here present in
hamburg
and we are active in hamburg in munich
and now
of course also online reaching
all over germany um we are doing the
women techmakers meetup when we are
having
off uh offline events normally we have
around 70 women present at our events
and we are also teaching women how to
code so
yeah to get more women into the field
and we are not only teaching
uh women who are already in their
careers how to code but we are also
thinking that the earliest you start
with the topic the the better that's why
we also started
teaching uh high school students and
also girls for
not even at high school yet and for all
this
uh concept we won the prize for digital
education initiatives
last year and also the price the digital
equality award of the city of hamburg
um yeah so yeah the concept
is about empowering and encouraging or
women of all ages to either stay in
technical roles or
to join technical roles
together with the tech companies that
are supporting us
and as i already said um we would like
uh girls to start early uh with this
topic
uh so we are offering programming
classes uh for girls
uh from the h5 on
and uh currently we have a group of
girls who we are preparing for the
um goodness we're informatics so it's a
global competition for
germany and we have a group
of girls that we are preparing for this
competition to also
um raise the race ratio of uh
girls participating we also think that
career
orientation is an important part so we
are offering a summer camp each year
um where girls have the opportunity to
meet all the tech companies that
are supporting us and also getting an
idea of
how future jobs look like
and for girls role models are also very
important that's why we
started portraying women who are
currently working in i.t positions
and you can find this this so-called
role model series on youtube
um for women who are already in their
careers
for women who are not in it careers yet
we are offering them classes to learn
about software development
and we are offering events like this one
where they can network with other
people who are already in the in the
industry and for women who are already
in
i.t positions there we are also offering
networking events and a community
and one thing where camilla is also
involved we started a mentoring program
this year and um
yeah we also of course always looking
for volunteers but we are also looking
for mentors
who want to also contribute uh to our
goal
and helping making
an individual change either mentoring
women who want to change make a career
change or girls
were in the start of their careers
these are a few just a few pictures
our classes where we are teaching to
girls are
a little bit different because we don't
have adult
mentors we have other girls that are a
little bit older those girls are
around 40 and 15 they already know how
to code and they
are mentored by us to teach the younger
girls
so this is a picture of our girls
programming classes
this is a picture of the career
orientation summer camp this year we had
to do it
online we had this year we had
google employees who helped us
uh do uh unconscious bias training and a
design thinking
a session to develop applications
against
unconscious bias busting with a group of
girls
this this is a picture of our
programming classes
um if you're interested in learning how
to code
um on thursday we have a python advanced
class starting
we also do conferences the last
conferences on the topic of blockchain
uh here you can see our second mayor of
the city of hamburg who also supported
this topic
and as i said we also have into
individual mentoring so if you're
looking for
mentors or if you want to be a mentor
please contact us and these are
our normal meet ups if we meet offline
they look at it a little bit different
than the normal tech meetups
from the audience
yes and again i of course always have to
think the companies that are making this
possible
and yeah that's it um if you want also
want to engage
in more in world please contact us or
contact me or
carmilla and now i would like to hand
over
to camilla again i guess
thank you so much anya i'm just going to
share my screen here again
very good creation
okay now you can hear me right yes now
he can hear you
okay as you know pi data is driven by
volunteers like us
so we always start with a small call for
participation
that's what open source is about and we
are especially looking for speakers
we're trying to give you
two talks every two months so if you're
building something interesting with open
source
data tools if you're using them in
interesting applications
or building these open source libraries
yourself
feel free to talk to us we would be
happy to host your talk
talk to the community about it and we
want to especially
encourage uh speakers from
underrepresented groups
and also first time pi data speak so
we're really
happy not just to host your talk but
also to provide you some
feedback and support in preparing your
talk
um clearly we could also use a few more
volunteers to
organize meetups we are really trying to
be an open
organization here you can be involved
easily in meetup planning
in outreach to speakers recommending
speakers
and supporters here so we're very
welcoming of that
and someday we may go back to
hosting meetups in the physical world
we don't know when that's going to be
and at this point sponsors become
relevant again
if you can sponsor a venue in the future
please talk to us you can really earn
some open source karma here
all right next slide please another call
for
participation um as you know covet 19
interfered with a lot of the
physical location conferences this year
but it wouldn't be pi data if there's
not
a quick replacement or
alternative um this is the call for
participation for pi data global that's
the first
global online pi data conference and
it's happening
in november november 11th to 15th
um the call for participation is open
and
it's just open until august 2nd so
no time to lose if you would like to
send in a talk proposal be quick
and there's also i see some support some
workshops helping you formulate a
good talk proposal
okay so you know moving
the meetup online was initially plan b
cohort 19 interfered with our first
planning two but i really liked the
possibilities that it opened for example
the chance to have
guest speakers from all over the world
last time vincent joined us from
amsterdam
and this time it's my pleasure to
introduce sivan who's joining us
directly from israel
so siva is a computer scientist
in fact a colleague from the area of
algorithm
development really focused on computer
vision and machine learning algorithms
and she's looking for a company named
healthy io
and they're developing a solution for
wound documentation and measurement
where you can
only use a single smartphone to do the
documentation measurement
so obviously that's a medical
application we're going to see some
medical photos
so be prepared especially if you brought
dinner to our meetup
nonetheless really fascinating topic
also technically
connected to machine learning neural
networks computer vision
photogrammetry graph algorithms
really looking forward to learning about
this so
please welcome sivan
hi thank you i'm going to share a slide
so
tell me if you see the correct okay
i can't share my slides
nope
okay i think you need to stop your
screen so i will be able to share mine
please try again
okay so you see the presentation yes
great okay so hello
i am stephen and i'm a computer vision
and machine learning
algorithm developer health cio health io
is an israeli startup based in tel aviv
that aims to turn the smartphone camera
into a medical device
today i'm going to talk about the
product that i am part of
which is called spot spotted is a
digital tool
for standardized wound assessment it
allows clinicians
clinicians to visually track a patient's
wound in a real time
by giving automatic measurements of the
wound and showing
images from previous visits
here you can see the general flow of our
product
when a patient comes to see the nurse
when a patient comes to the clinic
the wound assessment is done by the
nurse the nurse take a video
of the wound as you can see here and
then
a and then the nurse can document all
the necessary data
about the wound like tissue distribution
a
pain level and more after that she
uploads
all this data and later she can see it
in our dedicated website in our sport
proton
she can see all the data and the
measurement from our algorithm
a in this website
not only this nurse can see it but also
other nurses
and all other relevant clinicians can
enter to this portal and see the
relevant data
regarding this visit and all previous
visits as well
before we start i will just warn you
that we are going to see images of woods
it's not a real wound our data is
private so we can share with you our
real data
it's a makeup wound but it looks pretty
good
so just keep in mind that it's not a
real one
so let's start let's start with the
algorithm flow
of a of our product so the first thing
is that the nurse takes a video of the
wound as you can see here
this wound is not a real wound
and though it looks like one the nurse
takes a video
of the wound and after that she marks a
cross
on one frame from the video this cross
represents
the width and the length of the wound
which we will later
measure it using this cross
we can also calculate the segmentation
we can also find the boundaries
of this one for a for letter calculating
the area
of the world so how do we do it one
option
is to calculate all the measurements
directly from the 2d images
but as we all know our body is not in
the 2d space but
in a 3d space and because we want to be
as
accurate as we can we build a 3d model
using the video we just
saw and use this 3d model for
calculating the width length
and the area of the wood
the stickers that you see here are used
for the for calibration
they have a fixed size so it helps us to
understand the scale
they help us to to know how to convert
the coordinates from the 3d model into
the real world into centimeters
this is an example of the model you can
see here this is the 3d model that we
built
from the video we just saw in the
previous line
this is the model the wound the stickers
and in a few seconds you will see how we
project
the segmentation you see in the image in
right
into the 3d model
so this is the projection of the
segmentation this area will be used
later for calculating the wound area
when we finish all the calculation all
the algorithm flow
the nurse can see all the results in our
website
in the proton you can see here the the
automatic measurements width and length
and the area
and here you can see the cross the nurse
marks on the application
and our segmentation
in addition to all those measurements
the nurse can also see
a a representative frame from previous
visits of the wound
so this representative frame is the one
that we chose
okay so we chose we choose frame from
each
previous visit so the nurse will be able
to see it in a unified way
we want to find the most uh close
the most close file the frame that have
the the closest
point of view
so now that we talk about the algorithm
and about the application
we'll talk about the interaction between
them our algorithm
runs a on the cloud it's written
all in python and we need to interact
between the application and the
algorithm
so we have our application when the
nurse finish
and upload all the data the video goes
uploaded to google storage
and the other data is sent to our
backend in order to be saved in the
database
then the backend triggers a salary task
each task is can be one algorithm
overflow of several algorithms
this task enters to a queue in revit
which is then a can be
taken from the skew using our dedicated
workers
this those workers are listening to the
queues and when a new task enters
to a queue one worker take this task and
run
our algorithm when the algorithm finish
it uploads all the manuals again to the
storage
and send all other data to the backend
in order
to be saved in the database
and now for the fun part let's talk
about
python all our algorithms are written in
python
and today we will focus on two main
two main parts the first one is the
segmentation
which is written in pi torch and the
other one
is our 3d models which we use a
two python packages try mesh and network
gigs
let's start with the segmentation so i
guess all of you or most of you are very
familiar with python
so we use a way with by torch sorry
so we use pytorch for building our
network
uh our model is unit based so as you can
see here
this is a unit we have a we get
an input image we have encoder and
decoder
and output a segmentation map which is a
probability map
for each pixel how this network uh the
confidence of the network for this pixel
of being
a wound in our case in addition to the
unit part of our network
we have another part
that launched the important features
regarding the shape of the object
in our case the vulnerability of the
wound shapes is high
and the contours are not always clear
this additional part helps us to learn
better the wound boundaries
which is very important in our case
because we want to use the segmentation
for calculating the area so we need a
really good segmentation
and to get accurate area
the input to the network
is a crop of the wound using our cross
we can crop the wound and an additional
channel
which contains the four points of this
cross
what it means that we have using this
cross we have an additional data we have
a prior knowledge
about about the wound boundaries we can
give this prior knowledge to the network
to help her
to learn where are the boundaries of the
wound so we just add it as a force
channel to the input
and the output like a regular
segmentation output is a pixel rate
prediction with the probability
for each pixel of being a wind
in our training process we use data
augmentation
so we do data documentation on the
images
and on the process so here you can see
the data augmentation
on the images we crop we crop the images
in different sizes of bounding boxes
around the wood and we do flip resize
and rotate for each sample
the other death augmentation that we do
is that augmentation on the cross points
as you can see here we have different
sizes
of points and small translation for each
point
left right up and down why we do it
uh we don't want to enforce the network
to learn only segmentation that pass
through those points through the cross
point
we want the points to act as hints to
the network
regarding the boundaries using this
augmentation we give the network the
flexibility
to understand where the boundary is even
if it doesn't pass
through those cross points okay so i
will just
uh say again that describe the nurse
marks this cross in the app
in her phone so it's not always very
very
accurate uh so then so we want to give
the natural
flexibility to understand where uh where
exactly is the boundary
and the cross just give us a prior
knowledge about where it might be
so some called examples let's start with
the image
in the left the first thing that we do
in our training process
is to create a list of all the
augmentation that we want to apply
on every training sample so you can see
here flip
rotate cropping resize extreme points is
the four points
of the cross when we have those
augmentation
we can create a dataset object image
mask dataset is our class that inherits
from a dataset object of pytorch
that gets the images the masks and the
augmentation that we want to apply
this data set object with a we give to
the
data loader object which used later to
iterate
on all the examples in our data set for
the training process
in the right you we can see the image
mask data set the the dataset object
that we use the important thing here is
the get item function
that applies for each sample in our
training process
before feeding it to the network we use
we apply the get item function so here
we can do all the manipulation all the
augmentation transformation we need
on the image as you can see here we load
the image we create the mask we apply
all the augmentation
and we create a dictionary with all the
data and images that we need
to feed later to the network
so this was the segmentation and now
let's move on to talk about our 3d
models
so as we saw at the beginning we use 3d
models
to calculate all the measurements of the
wound
the first thing that we need to do is to
build this model
so we use a open source software it's
not python
it's called mushroom that given a set of
frames
uh it builds a 3d model of the scene in
those frames
uh those frame not necessarily a be from
the same video
it's just a set of frames that contains
the same object
that we want to build and as you can see
here
it builds the 3d model of the scene
and in addition it gives us the
positions of the camera that correspond
to each frame that we use
for building this model so we have the
point of view
of each frame relative to the 3d model
so what is the process the process of
building 3d model code
is called photogrammetry it's the
extraction of three-dimensional
measurements
from two-dimensional data how can we
build
a 3d model to do so we need a set of
frames
from different point of views as you can
see here in this example
and we have a set of frames different
point of view of the object
that we want to build to build the model
we need to find
corresponding points in each image
to other images and then using these
correspondences we can calculate
the depth and the 3d point
and the 3d point in the model
to illustrate this idea we can see here
we have four images
two points at each image we know the
corresponding points like this point
corresponds to this point in this image
and this point in the other image
and the 3d point that correspond to all
those
2d images is the intersection of all
line of sight
from each camera through the point to
the 3d
all the the intersection of all those
line of sight
is the 3d point in our model that we
want to build
so now that we have a our model we want
to use it
in order to calculate all our
measurement
so the first package that we use called
dry mesh
trench is a package for loading and
using triangular meshes
so when we when we want to use 3d models
we have two popular options of
representing
the model the first one is triangular
meshes this is what you see here and
what we use
we have a 3d surface that contains
a lot of small triangles
and the other option is called point
cloud
it just as it sounds it's cloud of
points it's like
taking all the vertices from this mesh
and creating a cloud
so in our case we use a triangular
measures and we use dry image
to manipulate it
we try which gives us a lot of
functionality to use
and manipulate this model the important
things for us
that we use is connected components
for example like you see here our model
is not clear
it has some artifacts and we have here
three components
uh in the model and we want only the
component
that contains the wound so using
connected components on this model
we can get the a
the relevant component that we need for
our calculations
trans also gives us a simple way to
apply transformation the scaling
rotation
and translation on the on the model
we can also divide each triangle each
each
mesh to sub uh to start triangles to get
even smaller triangles in the mesh and
get higher accuracy in our measurement
another functionality is to calculate
distance between a point to a mesh when
we want to calculate the distance
between the camera for a specific frame
to the mesh to understand the scale
this gives us a simple way to do it and
of course
visualization tools to see the mesh
so here you can see two examples of
creating a try mesh object
the first one is just loading
the 3d file the 3d model file if you
have ply file obj
stl you can just directly load it
the other option is the option that we
use we have a point cloud class
that contains all the relevant data that
we need about the point cloud
and in this case we explicitly pass
the vertices the faces and the colors
of the mesh into the constructor and
create a triangular
object
now that we have our mesh we want to
calculate the wound area
so doing so we want to cut the wound
part from the original model
and get a new object that contains only
the wound as you can see here
in the right for this we use another
python package that's called
networkx this this package is used for
network and graph analysis
the first thing that we do is to project
the segmentation that we're doing
that we saw in previous slides and we
project the segmentation into the 3d
model
then we convert our mesh into a network
x
graph and we will see in a minute how we
do it
and then using network x we can
calculate shorter
shortest path between each two points
each two consecutive points
in our segmentation so using this
functionality we can find a path
between all the segmentation points and
cut
the wound part from the model and get a
new object that contains
only the wound when we have a new object
that contains only the wood
it's pretty easy to calculate the area
it's just summing
all the triangle all the triangles that
we have
a in this object
so how do we create a graph we take the
mesh the tri-mesh object
we already have we take all the edges of
this mesh
on the length of the those edges the
length is the distance the 3d distance
between
each two points we create a network x
a graph object and iterate over the
edges and the length and add
it add each edge to the graph
when we have this graph we can find the
shortest path between each two points
so we iterate over our segmentation
point
uh look for the shorter path between
each two points
then here you can see that we take to
to get a close path we add the path
between the last point
in the segmentation list to the first
one and
using the this path we can crop the wood
part
from the entire mesh and of course if it
doesn't find
a find a pet between the two points that
we want
it weighs exception and it's pretty easy
to understand it
so just to summarize what we what we
just saw
so we talked about spot this is a wound
assessment tool that we developed at a
healthy io
we talked about the product flow the
algorithm flow
the interaction between the application
and the algorithm
then we saw the segmentation that we
used using pytorch
and the 3d models how we build them
using mushroom and how do we manipulate
them using
time mesh and network eggs
that's it if you have questions
i will be glad to answer thank you so
much stevon
i think we should mention that we asked
steven to prepare a talk for us about a
week ago
so i think that deserves another extra
round of virtual applause
don't know the button thank you
so questions um if you're shy you can
type them into
the chat and we're taking them from the
chat but
feel free to also raise your hand and
we're going to unmute you so you can ask
a question directly
any questions any hands
everyone's overwhelmed by the great
combination of python tools
[Music]
maybe everyone close their eyes
nobody
then i have a question in the meantime
um
medical data is always a bit sensitive
topic right so was it very difficult to
acquire the right training data
making your segmentation models so
we have our data that we collect we have
a pilot
of our application with the several
clinics
so we use this data to train our
networks
but we don't have enough data to train a
big network so we do a lot of data
augmentation
because yes it's pretty hard to get
to get a good data there are some data
sets
of wounds uh in the web but they look
very very
very different from our uh from the one
that
we use that we get in our clinics so we
don't really
a useful for us so we always get more
data
using our application but it's still not
enough
and i don't know if you mentioned it but
is transfer learning an option here or
do you
always train from scratch no no transfer
learning for now
oh there's a question in chat now from
alex
and alex asks how is the confidentiality
of the medical data preserved ensured
through the pipeline and cloud storage
so all the data is a in in the storage
it's only in the media it's only the
frames
without the data about the patient
the data about the patient is saved in
the database
uh in a way that i'm not really know
how it's not the algorithm part
er but
but we have this in mind when we save
all our data
and another question from sophia is the
company working in a collaboration with
the hospital
yes we have some we have clinics
and we now restart also with hospitals
yes
any more questions for steven
here's one from samoa is the app
considered a medical device
if so how does the regulation work in
this case do the models need to be
interpretable to get
the app approved so the app
is a medical device
and we we have a strict regulation about
it
most of them we have about uh regarding
the measurements
so we do a clinic trust to
to prove that our measurement that we
give them in our automatic measurements
are good
are accurate enough and regarding the
segmentation so
what we did for now is we are output
the segmentation and we give it a to
nurses
and doctors to see and to visually tell
us how good it is or
how it's not how we need to improve it
and because we use the segmentation also
for the wound area
so it's it's another way to understand
if our segmentation is good because
if it's not that accurate our wound area
won't be accurate as well
so it's validated by expert feedback um
i wonder what
interpretable would mean in the case of
your segmentation
do you have an idea on that i think in
some
some cases it in some cases segmentation
doesn't work very well
so i guess we would like to have some
idea about why the network chose
uh to put the contour in a specific way
and not in another
in another pixel
but they i i don't really i don't really
know
a few more questions um
olaf is asking what is the main
advantage of having a 3d model
with segmentation versus showing images
and the video to the doctors
versus again showing and showing images
and
mini model helps us to get more accurate
measurements if we want to calculate the
wound area we need the 3d model
to calculate it and not only the 2d
because of the curves
we have in our body
so evelyn asks is the manual interaction
required or is it possible to have a
completely automatic segmentation
and how do you handle non-typical wound
shapes
so automatic completely automatic
segmentation is possible
but the the cross helps us to get even
a more accurate segmentation so for now
if we have the cross
uh we use it uh how
to handle non-typical wound shapes we
need
for now we try that our training data
will be
a will be as wider as we can
and include the most
uh the most non-typical shapes that we
get
it's not cut and we just add it's not
only non-typical
uh shapes is hard but also wounds that
the boundaries is not very clear
it's also a hard to learn where is the
boundary
okay now questions keep coming a few
more from the chat
mel asks is the track of the camera
location
angle motion relative to the wound or
problem
when it is tried by users for building a
3d model
do you get what email is asking for not
really
i i will answer if if i understand you
correctly okay
the the nurse needs to take the video in
a very specific way
that will contain enough features
uh to find correspondences between
images and
enough frames from different point of
views
in in the cases that we don't have
enough point of views so
we have a problem to build a 3d model
from this video
this is what you meant
male confirms yes
okay one more question by jonas
how's the perception by the nurses do
they already recognize it as helpful
or perceive it as a threat of their jobs
no they recognize it as a helpful and
just
yesterday we got a an email from a
clinic that we work with
with very good words and that we very
help them
to understand to understand what
treatment is better
for this wound to get visually a
assessment of the wound for this visit
and previous visit so it's very easy for
them to understand how the wound
develops over time
and also if in the next visit the the
patient see
another nurse that didn't sit saw them
before
it's easy for for the new nurse to catch
up with all the previous visits
of the for this patient
okay let's thank sivan again for the q a
thank you
and camilla i can hand over to you
very good so i think we are right on
time uh
we would have now before we start the
talk with
aaron uh a 10 minutes break so now it's
uh 7 20 so 7 30 we see you again here we
are going to leave the chat open so
feel free to interact in 10 minutes we
are back
oh welcome back everyone should we
get started are people here with us
yeah i see people turning on the good
good i see humans that's very good i see
some movement so that means we didn't we
didn't we didn't
lost so many people so that's they're
always very good
we just wait one more minute and then we
get started
i don't i have to say i like very much
your picture looks very colorful
like it thank you thanks for that it
always brings me a lot of joy you know
like
just good vibes
yeah i also have a picture in a suit but
um
i thought it's okay to be more casual it
is and you know like it's
you know we need to be a little bit more
authentic with stuff you know like i
think it's
this yeah so
i really appreciate it it's yeah more
relaxation so i mean we're not doing a
job interview here right or whatever
even that like i mean
so should we get started
i think so very good so i'm very happy
to it was very
i don't know if see vanessa still with
us i would like to say
thanks a million like ten thousand times
because she really prepared this talk
within one week
uh it was very interesting topic i'm
also happy now to have
uh arun spring with us he's going to
give a talk on python for big data in
climate science um and i'm just going to
read for you here we have a headline for
that
so climate scientists analyze massive
amounts of data to understand
the earth system around 30 petabytes for
the upcoming ipcc report and maybe i
think iron can give
us an idea on how much 30 petabyte means
of data later on frameworks such as xray
and dusk extend numpy to handle these
larger than memory data challenge
and arrow is going to show us which
demonstrate a workflow a workflow
from the viewpoint of a climate data
scientist
and invite us to play around with public
available climate data so
thank you so much for being with us out
on stage is ours
thank you very much so
sharing the screens
i hope you can now see
my slides um thank you very much
for the kind introduction welcome to
this showcasing of
big data in climate science
very happy for people who
keep their video turned on
to get some visual feedback please also
use the chat for
for questions on the go and feedback if
i would be talking too slow or
too fast in in content or by audio
um so the goal
my goals for today is to convince you of
the power
of x-ray on the one hand and on the
other hand to give you a glimpse on how
climate data scientists can work
with python how am i going to do this
first i'll give you some intro on
climate models climate data
and our toolboxes for around 15 minutes
then and this will be the main thing of
my presentation here will be a live demo
computation and visualization on those
very new climate simulations and this
will be like looking over my shoulder
for around 20 minutes and lastly
i will give an outlook on science in the
cloud
and give you a link on actually the same
notebook tutorial that i've been showing
you
for yourself to play around with this
public data but first about myself
i studied physics in heidelberg and
started a phd in in hamburg two years
ago
at the max planck institute for
meteorology
and my phd topic is
about the variability and predictability
in the global carbon cycle and so it's
the question whether we can predict
short-term atmospheric co2 variations
due to natural climate variability i got
into python
during my master thesis and then
switched completely for my phd
um to python and my largest contribution
to open source software is
klimprad which i'm developing
with a colleague based in the us and
it's basically a multi-dimensional
forecast verification
package
talking about big climate data what
what is it and how does it look like
it's mostly
multi-dimensional data labeled data and
mostly
quite regularly formatted
data at least when it's coming from the
same source
meaning from the same same data center
so in geosciences
dimensions we are very often dealing
with are
called time longitude latitude
or depth height those kind of things so
examples of climate data would be
weather forecasts climate simulations
satellite product um but also
there are also other multi-dimensional
data and in other field that for example
xray
is is used for for example in finance
stock have a price then
given um to a certain time and also
price
location where traded and so on
usually all the data is stored in the
net cdf
format which builds up on hdf5
and but recently there's also
the possibility to store it in the tsar
format which is
optimized for chunk data which gives
actually quite nice performance with
with task and in the cloud
um yeah what is a climate model or an
earth system model as we call it
um an earth system model is
basically a dynamic representation of
coupled processes
with numerical equations so we try to
understand the earth system the world
and models because there we can control
all the processes we put in there
and basically we can switch on and
switch off stuff
do simulations and visualize those
results those um climate models are
actually
the base of them is often already
quite old code written in fortran and
then
npi parallelized um
and just to get a get an idea
of um yeah of the output or of
the scales of data that has been used if
we want to
simulate one year of processes
in the earth system with the mpi model
developed here in hamburg in the low
resolution configuration
the standard output is about 14
gigabytes of output
and it takes five node hours
um of power basically
um to to compute this here in this
picture on the right
and you you see the earth in a in a
gridded fashion
so in all these small boxes the
equations
um that have been put into the model are
solved and then coupled
that means a transfer of energy or
momentum or carbon
between those individual boxes into all
directions that also means
coupling of for example the atmosphere
carbon in the atmosphere with carbon in
the ocean or carbon in the atmosphere
with carbon in the land model
that's what i'm mostly mostly looking at
yeah so how does the workflow of this
analysis without python usually
usually looks like
so most of the work is usually done
in the shell even the climate model
is usually a fortran binary then started
from
long bash scripts and
for analysis we are mostly using domain
specific languages and tools
one is ncl developed by a research
institute in the us
the other one or another one a very
popular one is cdo
climate data operators um
which is actually an mpi here in hamburg
in-house development which is very
robust and also quite fast
but it's generating lots of intermediate
files usually so
from a reproducibility standpoint
it's sometimes a bit hard to to follow
what has been happening
very few people use also proprietary
software such as matlab
um but in general there's a slow shift a
slow shift towards
python especially with this ncl language
being
deprecated and lately
the disadvantages from my um perspective
in this
workflow is that usually it's very long
scripts
we are doing lots of copy pasting in
general
because also a few of us have any
software engineering background or
training
and um also with those tools mentioned
here
we often use different software for
computation and then for visualization
so there's always this kind of platform
or tool tool gap to do and another thing
and there's little reproducibility with
the intermediate files and
not too much of a code sharing culture
it's sometimes hard to to try to
understand from a computational point of
view
how the results have been achieved and
in general
any output of of climate data should be
highly reproducible
because it would be yeah it's just a set
of
calculations that has been done on those
data
what is data science for me in general
it's telling
a story based on data
analyze available data and visualize
results currently in research there's
lots of technical burns with
large data and with many data sets which
makes it a bit hard to get to the actual
science
as much of data handling data cleaning
and and those kind of things but ideally
it should be a rather intuitive and easy
this technical stuff and then there's
more
more effort to to make the science
really
really shine and to conceptually show um
what what you want to show with the
science nevertheless
we are still showing nice things with
with climate data which you will see
in in the live demo and
to make all these computational things
rather easy
and that you also don't have to
understand have to understand
everything under the hood the pangea
ecosystem and the python scientific
toolboxes and ecosystem and that
pangea platform is actually a very good
um good starting point
to do so so quickly want to pitch
pangeo it's a community platform for big
data science
to open community open source software
and infrastructure is
kind of a brand organized and
communicating mostly via github
and these are the tools that we are
working
on um there are working with the
software stack we are using
um so in python we are obviously using
this modular approach to
problem solving so we are starting with
python at the base
with some base functionality such as
numpy
and then increasing levels of
abstractions up to very specific
second learn machine learning stuff
everything that is
circled here in red i will somehow
use be using today
um how does high performance computing
architecture look like usually we have
some
distributed data storage which is kind
of
analysis ready um then we have some
parallel computing system and
which does the i o and computation with
x-ray
and task and then the visual interface
for the user is achieved via jupiter
now i'm going to introduce to you the
the two toolbox or under the
three main software items i'm i'm
working with
the first one is x-ray
that is for analysis of
multi-dimensional
data um
we are working here with self self
describing data
uh so usually with the data we don't get
only the values but also metadata really
explaining
the data um under the hood
x x-ray is using numpy and das in the
live demo you can really see how x-ray
is
from my point of view more
straightforward than just be using numpy
especially when you're in high
dimensions
it's quite easy to work with especially
if you have a background
in pandas or numpy because the api
is um is very similar
there are two data types in x-array
one is the um
one is the x-ray data array which is
like a numpy
array with denim dimension names and
coordinate names and coordinates
so there's no need to remember the axis
ordering
and stuff when you're doing the
selection and all the metadata
that i've been talking about is
stored into into attributes
um so when you have
usually when you when you're looking at
climate data output you have
many variables and each variable
is represented by a data array
um so the second data type is an x-ray
data set
um which is kind of a container of
one or more variables so in the
um in the lower part of the of the
slide you can actually see
three-dimensional data of temperature
and precipitation
as cubes and then latitude and longitude
are
coordinates describing that data and
time
describes the remaining dimension
and this is very very useful to
to handle and work with the data as
you'll see
in the live demo next is das
under the hood um xra uses
uses desk so task is a dynamic task
scheduler
so ideally the user doesn't need to
worry too much about
parallelism but still can use it
for x-ray and and large data and climate
task chunking allows out of allows to
compute out of
memory computations so for example if
you have a
satellite product data set of
more than 100 gigabyte larger than ram
um desk would break up this large array
into smaller parts
that even a laptop could handle so tasks
is scaling nicely from a laptop but also
to a supercomputer
and um is also built around a common
linear one api um
so how does task actually actually
work with data that three data types
which are very similar to known
implementations
um x array is mostly or is is using task
array which is similar to the numpy
array
and as you're working with a dash
collect
collection with a task array
every time you want to do some
mathematical operation
this new task is added to a task graph
so over time you're not computing the
data but you are
creating a task graph and
only then in the end when
you're building this task graph but the
data is not computed immediately
only once you hit dot compute
um this task graph is then sent to the
schedulers and
then only all the calculation is
is done and depending on your system on
your resources
there you can redistribute the workload
over
over many machines we'll see an example
of this
um and lastly um
a new tool suite
i've been working with for for a few
months now
is is intact and intake is there to make
data access
just yeah easier when does intake really
make sense
when you find yourself otherwise
plugging together long strings of
paths you want to access repeatedly and
and so on so the idea of intake that is
that you're building a catalog in the
yaml file once
and then based on that catalog you can
find and investigate and share
data sources easily
those catalogs can also be version
controlled and
interx allows it to make a nice
distinction between the roles of a data
curator or a data analyst
um there is also a plugin for intake
x-ray to access net cdf files
and even a plug-in um to
for esm output where
um you can query for the data sets you
you really want to analyze and um they
are then
nicely outputted into x-ray
via desk and this is will be the main
part
of the live demo so
now i will
go soon out of the slides to start the
live demo
which um where i will be computing on
a super computer here in hamburg and
keras at the german climate research
center and here in the slide you see a
picture
and um usually it's actually also
possible to
to go there on on tours to walk through
the supercomputer
uh like not by your own but you'll
you'll get a tour by someone who is
working there
i think due to the corona situation
that's right now not possible
but i heard from christian that he
really liked it when he was there once
yeah and then later i'll provide you
also a link
where you can actually do the same or
very similar
tutorial with public data in the cloud
okay now i have to get out here
i will share a different part of my
screen now
okay can you see the
the jupiter notebook now
great i have to get all the zoom stuff
out here
okay now um i used ssh
to to get um onto the supercomputer
and first we will just be loading
um a common common observational data
set
um the old way without having x array
so when there is the there is a net cdf
package
you can open a dataset and net cdf as i
said is a self-describing data format
and this is what i mean by this um so
here
the wrapper for this data set ds reads
that it's near surface temperature data
given by the met office which is the uk
weather office
you can even have a reference um paper
to that and and so on
and then you can see okay how what are
the variables that are
in this file we find this temperature
normally there you can
[Music]
look at the time and
you can also if you remember that the
time
or if you see the time is the first axis
you can as you would do a numpy do sub
selection of the first time step
okay i somewhere didn't click something
um
so temperature
um and if we look here at this last time
step we see that it is
um actually a numpy array
and number arrays we could easily plot
with matplotlib but then we just have
some data values or some colors but we
don't have any reference around it
we only see see numbers we don't have a
unit don't have a color bar
don't have anything about the scales we
are seeing
it and it would be
quite difficult in this workflow to plot
the the climate at a given point in time
or
just to extract the time series for a
single location
like like handbag like hamburg and for
this
x-ray was um was developed
where um many features of this
of this um data format net cdf
were nicely integrated um
so there is a nice wrapper where you can
immediately see the dimensions and
coordinates
and data variables
and as we do mostly only want to work
with
temperature anomaly we can just extract
this
a data set is like a dictionary so we
can just
extract it by the key underlying data
can be accessed via values
here we see that it is a numpy array
and data sets
and x-ray data arrays have dimensions
and coordinates um which we'll
then be using um in our in our
calculations
all the metadata is going into
attributes
which is a dictionary again and
yeah okay so
plotting now is then gives
all those all this reference that i
would be hoping
uh i would have hoped um
to to see before so i can
do similar to pandas api and iselection
index selection take the last index and
plot it and then we see
actually longitude and latitude
given we see a nice color bar all the
metadata that is
kind of there and useful to to show
variable name or units
can be can be given and for rapid
prototyping
this is very very very useful
um then for plotting xray understands
matplotlib
api and for selection
it also understands the date time format
so with this i could easily plot for
this
specific point in time when the bottom
block came down
um the the climate
the global climate um
another thing would be to plot
the time series for hamburg um
so i can also select by latitude and
longitude those are the values
um for hamburg and um
i'm selecting here in the nearest values
for um for hamburg from the data
because as you can see here it selects
from the data
the latitude the longitude 12.5 but
actually hamburg is more on the
longitude 10. um
otherwise it it would fail but it can
approximate the
the nearest uh value also
just giving you um some some idea how
the workflow with with the x-ray
then would be
and if we would now have the scientific
question
okay does worm does the earth
bomb overall or where is the strongest
warming is it rather the north pole or
is it the south pole or is it the
tropics
um okay actually i wanted to
um i wanted to build up this plot
step by step
um so just the first naive plot
would be would be this one
as we want to look in which latitude
the the warming is the strongest we
would take a
mean over the longitude and then we can
transform the data
now we have actually monthly data
so we can use um
the group by command to get
annual data annual data is is a bit more
smooth
so we can do a time mean
and then we already see that we have um
cooler years and in the 19th century and
we are experiencing a warming
um towards um
our present day and that this woman is
actually much
stronger in the in the northern
hemisphere in the
over the poles and especially um in the
in the northern hemisphere and
the data set is now an anomaly towards
the 70s to 90s
of the night er of the 20th century so
we can also
reset this anomaly towards beginning of
this time series
similar to this pre-industrial what the
paris agreement is always talking about
and there we see
that actually um
in the high up north we already have uh
quite strong quite strong warming as we
have also
seen for the for the hamburg time series
so this would just be the workflow of
working with one file but um
then there is the cmip6 and
and which stands for coupled model
intercomparison project
so all the climate models for this new
ipcc report
released in two years they do many many
simulations
so they all do this historical
simulation from 1850
to 2015 and then they do
so many other experience
experiments for example about different
scenarios
where in one scenario um emissions
of fossil fuels are increasing very
rapidly and others which are
compatible with a maximum two degree
warming
or also we do experiments about
geoengineering
or experiments where we are
looking into specific things of the
carbon cycle
so in total this will be up to
30 petabyte data
and some of that data is downloaded on a
supercomputer in
in a very distinct folder structure
um and um
but it's not really it's not really
obvious
which files are actually there because
some files and some variables are
prioritized
then they are also processed
by a diff by a certain post-processing
which has this kind of name tag here in
the end
and to find out which data is actually
available
then intake is really really really
useful
um so with intake i can open a catalog
of all the files which are available on
that super
on our super computer and this is here
as you can see in total
we have four million files and this is a
vast amount of data
and all this collection is actually
accessible via a panda's data frame
where then we find here in the end the
path
but find all the other kind of metadata
about
different files so we have
the source id is is
the model name or the institution id
is the research institution actually
running that model
and then the experiment name and then we
often run experiments a couple of times
to to get a more robust answer because
those model simulations are not
deterministic per se
so as a first first question
or first thing i would just be looking
into global mean surface temperature
of the mpi model and
so the scientific question would be what
level of warming do
climate models simulate and the
challenge is that not
not all data is already downloaded and
this will be
specifically clear when we are looking
at all the models
and that are downloaded and but now for
simplicity to show how it works
i'm just selecting for one experiment
the historical
experiments or the most important or the
most basic experiment
um just increasing the co2 emissions as
they have happened um over those 165
years
then i'll look into atmospheric output
of the variable
temperature
of the atmosphere of the air near the
surface
and only i only want to get data from
the
from the hamburg model and then i find
these
only nine paths and then here intake x
array
has very much designed for our purposes
um oh no
to run this
um it has this
function to um
to extract all those data sets into a
dictionary
why a dictionary because different
models run on different resolution and
we couldn't concat
everything together which we'll see
which we'll see later
now to now we'll start the desk um
client to be able to see also
the magic in the dashboard
which you can see here on the
on the right
so we have this data data set
dictionary where we have a key and then
all the data and we just get out the
first data set
extract the data array
and then just look at into the into the
data there
and here we see 150 megabytes
um nearly 2 000 months
that's what we would expect resolution
of around 150 kilometers
but the data type here is now a das
array that's actually
lazy data so the data has not been
loaded yet
but only the metadata and because it's
nine files where we are only taking out
basically the variable and do nothing
with it
the workflow is actually embarrassingly
parallel
so those nine files can just be
accessed actually simultaneously
and only once we hit compute or plot
then that data is actually selected
here i would usually expect really the
first time step
that's why i do a sort by um
[Music]
the data is not always as as clear as
and cleaned as we would hope for um
usually we look at just annual averages
not we don't want to be distracted too
much by the
by the seasonal cycle um therefore i
define here my your mean function
and if i now apply this your mean
function
over the whole data
it reduces the data by a factor of 12
but it also creates lots of chunks and
many tasks
those tasks haven't been computed yet
and this is this famous
task graph and only once i hit here
compute
you'll see in the dashboard that all the
work
is done and here you see also in our
climate model
the temperature is rising especially
since the second part of the 20th
century now
as and here we see
the really large task graph which is
so large that it can cannot be nicely
rendered
now there's one one nice trick
um to actually get less
chunks and less tasks to use x-ray
mark map blocks where
we are mapping actually a calculation
onto each chunk
and this has the big advantage that we
are reducing the number of tasks and the
number of chunks
um massively which you can see here also
in the um in the task graph
here you can still identify the nine
different
um files where basically on each file
this year mean operation
is um is mapped directly
um yeah so this is one case where we
don't have this
thing of either having more chunks or
less or more tasks
but really we can reduce both of them
um the and the upside of this
is that with matte blocks we can compute
it a bit faster
because um each
task comes with a tiny overhead in
in dusk but on this low uh data
challenge
it doesn't make too much of a difference
but sometimes this can
decide whether a workflow works or it
doesn't work
but now a really must use case for integ
esm would be the scientific question
which level
do all the models simulate
and now i'm basically doing exactly the
same thing as before
i'm just not selecting only the hamburg
model
selecting for searching for just leaving
that key open
that means it takes all of them and
except for the ones
that i don't want to have there which
were failing when i prepared this
um but now um
here we can actually um
search for how many
are available of these models and it's
around 40 models that have um this
simulations from 26 institutions
and in total it's nearly 400 files
and searching these files by hand would
be super super annoying
but this is how the workflow
has has been in the past
um then we can do the same thing
to get all this data into into
dictionaries this is still lazy data
so we are not loading data yet once
we're dealing with actual data handling
we would be seeing this here in the
dashboard um
this now takes a few seconds
um
yeah then once this is
done um we will be actually looping over
this dictionary before we only had one
item in the dictionary that wasn't
it wasn't the thing but now we would be
looping over the
dictionary take out
this one variable do a spatial mean
because we want
to get the the warming over the whole
globe
in a sense and
here we do the mean calculation and then
we are appending this to a list and
getting and concatenating all the data
together
um this is very useful because then
afterwards we can just easily work with
this file
so now all the basically all the
metadata has been
has been loaded and accessing now
building this task graph
you'll see is extremely fast
okay is there now a new model
that's the problem sometimes new
stuff is downloaded um
i will check so sorry for the live
modeling
term size equals x
so the data formatting although there is
a current a
set of lists a set of rules and that is
expected um for the output to be
followed
it's not always that clean
so now i'm just checking that the time
is expected yeah okay now it works um
so still no data has been
has been uh read from disk only
the metadata um and now we see all those
36 models are there we collapsed all the
special data so we only have the time
information
and um this is two thousand
like three nearly three thousand tax
tasks in which we are collapsing 10
gigabytes
to less than um than a megabyte and this
now is
when all the um when all the action is
working
so now the parallel like the node i'm
working on has
um there's nearly 50
cpus available and now das
is organizing all this parallel workflow
where i don't really have to do
much now
i see a question now in a chant um the
special mean
whether and the question is whether the
special mean takes into account the
weight
of the latitudes here um here in this
simple um in this simple use case i
didn't do this
but um you can easily apply um
weighting by latitude which is usually
done
um to account for the geometry of the
earth
usually we do this to calculate
this gmst um here for simplicity
i didn't do yeah but
good point um so usually
i'm also saving this now to disc um
because
this kind of operation i only need to do
once in a while maybe
once in the beginning and then before i
would be submitting a paper
not every time i start the notebook or
analysis
um because you see it takes a bit of
time it should be on
taking yeah roughly two minutes
and that all this calculation
is is done um and
once data is saved to disk then it's
really fast to
to be loaded again so now we can look
actually at data
and we see those 30 models we see a huge
um annual annual cycle because it's
still
monthly data and we see that all these
models have a different
base based temperature level
and um
that is just a known unknown fact um
so in the end we'll be looking at an
anomaly plot like how much
warming has there been since the past
200 years um the best practice from my
point of view is try to get everything
into one file so
as i also want to show you how the
observations would be looking like
um i'm also quickly opening here at the
same observations as i've been showing
you before
for the same times um same spatial
aggregation
why does this snow
okay
yep
so actually open data set
url path should do the trick
yeah so we are opening this url path
i've defined at the beginning and
then we are renaming to concatenate it
and giving this
observations the model name on those
model dimension
axes and now we can actually
do the plot and all the science you are
you're seeing here is actually happening
happening in this one line all we're
doing is we take the data
after the spatial aggregation
we remove the mean
from the 60s to the 90s
and then do
the year mean over this and
um and then we can easily plot the data
and here we can see
like in red maybe it's a bit difficult
to
to see in red we see the observations
and in black we see the model mean so
the assumption is all models do mistakes
but they do
this mistakes in different areas so
often so the assumption is that more
some of the errors are canceling each
other out
and actually this multi-modal approach
is the best
estimate we are having from a modeling
point of view
and we see that it matches the observed
anomalies quite nicely
only for the last 15 years we see that
the observations are on the lower side
this has two reasonings on the one hand
this was the global warming hiatus
period
where due to internal variability there
was less warming than was expected
on the other hand new climate models are
actually more sensitive
to greenhouse gases than the old
models have been before
and then yeah maybe
just very quickly if you want to see how
the models are
forming okay
yeah i think i'll leave this and i just
show you the results
where do the climate models warm um over
the past
30 years we can see here
like x-ray has this nice facet grid
plotting functionalities that you might
know from seabourn
and it can unders can understand cardo
pie
so we can create this nice plot in just
those few lines
of code and there we see that
while the warming is happening mostly
everywhere
on the globe the warming is higher over
land and it's higher
over the especially near the north pole
which is a normal phenomenon it's called
polar amplification
and we see internal variability we see
here in the canadian model that there is
actually cooling
happening over europe that doesn't mean
that climate change is not real
um it can be due to internal variability
and often we are running the model a few
times to get this
internal variability contribution
smoothed out
because um the atmosphere is the cardiac
system and not
deterministic so very likely
the same model with slightly different
initial conditions
can also produce a warm trend there when
when re-running
yeah i think with this
i want to quickly return to the slides
um yeah my my best practices
usually i try to concatenate everything
all the data i have
into one x-ray data set and save this to
disk
just saves saves a lot of time once this
one's done
and if it's large data i do this in tsar
because the performance is just really
nice there
it's really helpful to try to understand
chunking to use das
the dashboard and then leverage intake
because this can really simplify the
live few
extensions with x-ray that i'm often
using with x-ray you can basically plug
in
every function also from sci pi via
x-array apply a u-func
so if you have um some some function
and that you really want to use but
somehow you cannot plug it together
that easily next way um you can
just put numpy code basically into x-ray
apply you func
and um this does all the broadcasting
and stuff
um for you yes my apologies
may i ask you a favor can you have your
present or mode
are you able to share uh as you were
before okay
yes sure make it a little bit bigger for
us
yeah sorry and now yes you know like my
eyes you know like you're getting old
your eyes sometimes are not that good
anymore
sorry i didn't i didn't want you guys to
see
um that i could be reading just my notes
off
um you now see the bigger screen right
oh yes oh yes
i can see it thank you so much okay i'm
close to the end anyways
but um yeah then with das job queue you
can actually parallelize the ask
across nodes especially on a super
computer super computer has like
a few thousand um cpu
nodes there you could actually really
parallelize
and make stuff um faster with
and then there is a list of packages
many of them
really specific to our um geosciences
um community um really under
pre-appreciated
package i would say is region mask where
you can do special aggregations based on
a shapefile which is something every one
of us is basically doing
but this is a really neat way of doing
it reproducible
and yeah
okay then um
second last slide um challenges from my
point of view in the
uh for big data climate stuff
um data set availability size
and the i o performance like from the
technical
point of view those are um
that's a big big bottleneck
when when you look at the workflow often
the
open data set function is the one which
is slowest and slowing uh
the other stuff down then the other one
is that the file systems are usually not
optimized to load many files python
python code but also in general many
files to concatenate
very fast a solution for both of those
is actually the pangeo cloud where the
pangea community
put much of the cmap6 data into
a google and amazon cloud and there
with the tutorial data which you can
soon or after this
in the evening can try out yourself
there you can the data is basically
sitting
as indicated here um right next to the
um to the compute nodes and
um figuratively speaking um
so there is lesser than bottleneck of
of io and then also in the cloud you can
just
increase the number of work of workers
working on your problem
quite much and by this this example that
i've been showing you
it took two minutes on the supercomputer
to load all these data
um on a in the cloud if you just use
two workers um it takes i think around
a minute or so and if you take 20
workers it just takes 10 seconds the
same calculation
and yeah this is something that you can
you can try out
um try out later um
challenges from the human perspective is
um
and that also includes myself rather
little knowledge about
of climate scientists in software
engineering writing tests continuous
integration
is is rather unknown and not that common
and in general parallelism
from the analysis point of view is not
that
not that much not that much used
we use obviously parallelism to run our
models because otherwise they wouldn't
be as fast
as they are last slide um
pangea is taking it really to the to the
extremes and
doing radically open science um
so the idea here is as you've seen the
data is in the cloud
on amazon and google clouds
and you can actually put up a notebook
onto onto github
and get this data connection there and
put your manuscript and the code
there to have it even on the version
control and then even the reviewers
could
could play around with the data this is
not really common
um it's also the question whether this
will be
the future of it putting everything on
github
but it's actually a very nice way of
working on the same super kind of super
computer in the cloud
to do the analysis and uh really share
a similar working environment for this
pen geo is just a really really nice
platform and i hope you're now curious
to
to work with um with this climate data a
bit yourself
so i prepared um the same pengio at
the same notebook in
the um in the cloud
how to get this away here
yeah okay so i can just post
like if you want to where is the chat
so i post now in the chat um where you
can find the slides and everything
and also if you want to try out
you can do the analysis
oops
yeah the second the binder the path with
binder
is actually um
the the same kind of notebook
but then you're connected to this i
think it's a google
google cloud okay this this was my talk
i'm happy to take
questions now
thank you so much i don't know there's
already questions here
okay great um
yeah i'm just have this open um
so antonio's is asking what is the
difference between desk and x-ray
also do they implement the full numpy
and pandas apis
so x-ray is like
yeah so x-ray is using task
and da and dusk array is basically
like numpy um
[Music]
but dusk has this advantage that you can
work with those chunks
both both software libraries didn't
implement the full apis but they
implement
many many many of the functions so also
the linear algebra for example
is implemented by task and if you're
missing something
they're really happy usually if you if
you raise an issue on github
and then either yourself or someone else
probably
will will implement missing missing
features
um about panda's apis it is similar
to pandas it's um i think
but still many of those things are are
actually
there another next question um
if we don't have net cdf files already
can x-ray read an arbitrary numpy array
and declare another array
as a coordinate yeah this
could this could work like it depends on
how your
numpy array is is saved
um so there there is
there is nice convenience function of
transferring
for example pandas data frames into
x-ray data and the other way around
also x-ray data into numpy
um data and these kind of things um so
i think this should somehow be possible
han can i ask you a similar question
have you started a workflow with pandas
and numpy
and then switched it to task
me yes
so when when i started
really only working with with python i
um
when i started working only with python
i
immediately started with x-ray so i
didn't have to convert any
other python code
like pandas code into into x-ray
[Music]
and can you estimate how much work it
would be is it basically a drop-in
replacement
then you get all of memory computation
and parallelism or do you have to
basically do a rewrite or something in
between yeah
and so for like if if you'd be using
before numpy and then when i use gask
then it's not too much of a rewrite
if you're switching from pandas um to
to x array that would be a rewrite but
then i guess if you want to use
pandas and want to leverage task
you should be working with dusk data
frames which is
kind of the deskified
pandas so they
yeah there's this three different types
of tasks
um it that should actually not be too
much of a rewrite
um but i'm not working too much with the
data frames to be honest
thank you um christian could you maybe
um go go on and read out the questions
that's
a bit a bit easier for me as you said
before
i think i just answered the first
question next one would be from mikhail
so mikhail said i'm working on a french
super computer where the
cm ip6 there are stored is that
possible to easily set up intake over
there
does it automatically map all the files
or should i do anything specific
um there is
um so actually i saw the guys in the us
developing intake esm and then i thought
oh i want to have this
at my super comp or at our super
computer here in hamburg
and i got in touch with them via github
and then i found out how it how it works
so
um actually you have to
like there is a script that generates
the large um
catalog um on your super computer with
your paths
with the files that are available on
your super computer
um but this can be you can find it under
intake esm
data store um
if you if you google for that or just
write me a message afterwards i can send
you the link
um once this is run and this takes an
hour or so
to because it just it walks over all the
paths
um in that one base directory um so that
so the nice thing is the file structure
on the french supercomputer for cm6 data
will be the same as the um as the file
structure on the
american or also on the german
supercomputers
um that's so-called similarized data
and once you've generated that catalog
then
you could be basically using the same
thing
on your on your french super computer
connected question if you're finished um
i didn't know intake i will definitely
have a look at intake um i was wondering
would you recommend this for almost all
data science workflows even with just a
few
data sources or is it really meant for
the cases in which you have a
huge complex catalog of data sources um
so my workflow before was well i have
had this one folder where i stored all
my observations
and then i tried to give them nice
useful names
but in the end yeah this after some
time just got a bit ugly and i saw
myself copy and pasting a lot
and um like i started using
catalogs now and sometimes in those
catalogs are only three four five
data sets in there but you can actually
also
do a catalog of other catalogs and then
you can
basically make this a super large thing
like in hamburg we have one department
only working with observational data
so they're doing lots of quality control
downloading data and so on
and i recently convinced them to
actually build a catalog on all the
ocean data that they are having and in
that
catalog are now i would say
20 to 30 observational data sets um
and intake is is very modular so there's
this base intake functionality
which is working a lot with fs spec
like some file system stuff um also for
caching
and then you can basically for any data
source you can write your own
intake driver so intake x-ray is a
driver that is
specifically in the end wrapping
x-ray open data set then um
if you have lots of csv files you're
working on that's i think even
implemented in the base
intake stuff i today was looking into
intake
geopandas to be able to read those shape
files
um like
since i found it a few months ago
i think this is really simplifying
simplifying life
especially when you also have remote
data those catalogs are super
lightweight
you can just put it in a gist like on
github
and send it to a friend and just with
this one
url your friend can basically open the
same
data if it's if it's open openly
available
so for me this i think this has really
the potential to
to be a really big like intake esm is
obviously
for us our system people um
but then it's probably probably you can
find
a nice um plug-in for many other use
cases
let's go to the question from gerardo um
regarding the data chunking when using
the ask
is there a special criterion you use to
recharge the data in order to speed up
computation
or just rely on the underlying net cdf
file chunking that's a very good
question so
general advice is when you
you really have to look how your
computation how your computation is that
it
that it really makes sense um
the chunking so there is no like you can
re-chunk
um you can do a chunk auto so
um desk figures out automatic chunks
or given on a given chunk size you can
set in the config file
but it really depends on your
computation when your computation is
basically
just over time you have some some for
your transform which you want to
apply over time and then basically your
whole workflow
is embarrassingly parallel over the
spatial dimensions
then i would advise to chunk only based
on the
special dimensions and leave time as
only one chunk to chunk minus one um
this is kind of this general advice what
i what i mean by you have to understand
what the algorithm is doing and then you
have to decide based on that
um how to do the chunking um what really
helps
is if you save your data in the tsar
format
because there you really specify the
chunks
more deliberately than with the net cdf
files it's usually
with net cd efforts most often you have
those hundred files and then
you have 100 chunks but with zarya you
can really read chunk
how you like and there's the sweet
chunker by the ngo community
where you can really
transform your um your one
several gigabytes file from only chunked
in in the time dimension to only chunked
in the space
in some special dimension which
otherwise is often
blowing up memory so there's a really
nice medium article
a article from ryan abernathy who is a
main force behind pengio
um describing this re-chunker that is
really
useful also to limit the ram usage
um while doing the sweet chunking
um yeah one more question
antonio is asking is it possible to
limit the ram usage
um i think theoretically it should be
but sometimes i also get this
uh get some ram
problems like when i somehow try to
create a data set with too many
dimensions
um then just size blows up
it should be possible somehow but i also
few times
run into this problem i don't know
okay you guys that's it thank you so
much aaron for the talk
thank you for that hands
let me just share my screen again so
guys now it's the moment you know like
because
we have our next meetup in september so
i'm just
passing by again here to say that we are
looking to keep in touch with all of you
and if you're interested in giving a
talk please reach
to us uh christian said that in the
beginning i'm going to reinforce again
for us it's very important
to keep track on this part of diversity
uh
so if anyone is interested to talk and
you because it's sometimes
people feel a little bit shy they think
that okay what i have here is material
is not good
so feel free to reach out to me or
christian we can support you like
coaching how to put out your
presentation how to get structure on
that
so do that and we hope to see you again
in september
thank you so much stephen uh and adam
for the talks it was very inspiring
christian last word um also thank you
anya for the collaboration and first of
all
and thanks for my word that's a very
important thing
thank you everyone stay healthy take
care bye bye and see you in september
bye bye